I have heard this law security false
insecurity where they say it's Putin's
War that's causing the inflation so I
think people think if we can just
weather this inflation once the war ends
it'll go it'll be over yeah I mean
there's probably still people that
believe it's transitory that's one of
the things that the government has been
had been telling the population for a
year leading up to inflation getting
really really bad oh it's transitory
don't worry about it it's only going to
be short term every time that we that
inflation was brought up for the past
two years or past year or whatever the
the Administration has downplayed it and
done its best to probably responsibly
keep the population from freaking out
but at some point they have to
acknowledge look it's going to be it's
not going to be as easy as it's not
going to be a soft Landing we're gonna
probably go into a recession probably a
serious one and until that happens I
don't think people are going to be like
oh you know things actually are bad